foreign
[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
today on the show is Jillian torrecki
she is a psychologist she's a certified
relationship coach and teacher as well
as writer man she just like has her
finger on the pulse of just such like
key issues that people experience in
relationships and Bam we just like
flowed and navigated through all of the
challenges and like what the
relationship's for and you know I
thought was fun is a lot of times we'd
be like here's a scenario and like okay
what's the right answer to that in a
good relationship okay what's the wrong
answer to that in a bad relationship or
that indicates one I mean relationships
are are here to teach us a lot of really
really amazing things there's some
people as she said that you know stick
it out and are miserable and you know
reframing an ending of a relationship
from being a failure to just an ending
and then there's others that don't fight
hard enough so hopefully in this episode
you can hear if you're wondering why
should I should I stay in this
relationship should I not what are these
like good sign means bad signs I hope
you like and learn a lot from from this
episode please hit the Subscribe button
I appreciate that every time it shows me
that my content is hitting home the bell
for notifications of the episodes and
give me your two cents in the comments
today's pretty intense partner is
athletic greens I take ag1 by athletic
greens literally every day I gave ag1 a
try because I wanted to nourish my gut
health I wanted to have more energy I
wanted to add more micronutrients to my
body I take it first thing in the
morning before I have coffee and then
before I go work out it makes me feel so
good I'm giving my body the nutrition it
craves if a comprehensive solution is
what you need from your supplement
routine then try ag1 and get a free
one-year supply of vitamin D and get
five free ag1 travel packs with your
first purchase go to drink ag1.com
pretty intense that's drink ag1.com
pretty intense check it out thank you so
much for doing this thank you for having
me oh I've been following your stuff
such a long time and like I just don't
know where you get your like density of
data it's like always so applicable and
it's so good yeah I don't how do you
what what do you what do you do that
keeps your finger on the pulse because
it always seems like even when I was
this morning just like double checking
all the things that I wanted to talk to
you about as I'm going through them I'm
making more notes I'm like man like
there's just so it's just so
informational and helpful
um I think it's because I've worked with
so many people and continue to work with
so many people and I have really great
mentors so I I that's the only thing
that I could really you know and I'm a
workaholic so maybe that's it but I you
know I I think it's mostly just because
I've worked with so many people and
because
I speak to two different mentors every
week one of them is just one of the best
like strategic family therapists like in
the world basically and she's an 80 83
year old woman so she keeps me very like
on my toes not to get seduced by what
everyone is talking about in the pop
psychology cycle so just to stay very
real you might need that name and number
someday I know exactly and then um the
other one also for like case studies and
and she's case studies and also
marketing stuff and all that kind of
stuff she's been with me since the very
beginning so yeah both of them have yeah
I think mentorship is so important I
think it's key like you have to have a
mentor of some sort whatever that really
looks like but I don't think that I
think we all need help you know life is
hard life this is not we don't we don't
come with a manual like we need
mentorship especially around work
relationships is all of it don't you
think yep I mean
yes and all I keep thinking about is how
relationships I think everyone would
agree they're hard even the ones that
last 50 years they're like oh there was
some tough times yes like
yeah there can be phases and long
periods of time where it's not hard but
yeah you know with enough time and
duration you're gonna get there yeah so
you talk about like having these mentors
as really part of your team to to be
able to achieve highly and everyone does
relationships yet they're they're not
the thing that we're really taught about
we're not we don't learn anything about
them in school we're we're our parents
aren't you know the birds and the bees
conversation doesn't even happen about
sex bro I'm sure like let alone like hey
how's it going I mean the best thing
that comes like it seems like one of the
only things that comes from family and
friends is like I like them I don't like
them or I like writing totally totally
I'm attracted I'm not attracted man it
seems like there's a gap
there's a really big gap and therapy
used to be super like uncool and weird
and thank God at least that's come along
yeah I asked my parents I was like do
you guys ever think about going to
therapy and this was like a year or two
ago and my mom looked at me and she's
like no and I'm like
no I mean like it's not even uncommon
I'm a Jewish New Yorker so it's like if
you're a Jew from New York
new house no one's in therapy why is
that I mean I think it's just people are
becoming more aware of the fact that
they need help right and that we can't
actually do it alone and I think that
technology has played a big role in this
because it's the sharing of information
it's moving very fast so now people are
like wanting to
um feel more connected right and so when
people are noticing oh I don't feel as
connected
and you know and that's part of
technology and it's like how do I feel
more connected and then also technology
technology spreading sort of you know
also the wisdom of just like these are
the things that you need to think about
so I think that part of it is the info
it's the positive influence if you will
of technology I think it actually plays
a pretty big role
um and so yeah it's like you know it's
it's just culture things move in sort of
In Waves and so part of our culture is
advancing in terms of how we think about
mental health and I think technology
definitely plays a really large role in
that and I guess Evolution plays a role
in that honestly getting to the place
where you're like where people are they
want to evolve
you know they actually want to grow yeah
and whereas that wasn't something that
was really of a particular interest to
people in in in uh previous generations
because well the expectations around
roles and work was very different now
especially in our culture it's like we
can be anything we can grow and be
anything and so I think that technology
and culture plays a huge role not
well and it's more acceptable to evolve
and grow they might not I don't even I
don't even I wonder if they even said
the words I am trying to grow and evolve
like no there's also a stigma around
changing as if changing is like
abandoning yourself and your upbringing
in your family because you're changing
but if I'm like I'm I'm always trying to
change for the better you talked about
role you said the word roles and it made
me think about you know what's the role
of a relationship because we can look at
you know you look at work and and and
role meaning like why is it hard so
everything is hard if you want to be
really good at it if you want to be good
at your job like there'll be attrition
and
you know you'll have to take a take a
low paying job or you'll have to take a
low-level job and where you'll have to
do some grunt work like there's
everything that you want to be great at
there's challenge there's time and
challenge yeah you know for work you're
like I'm trying to have some self-worth
and earn some money right or
you know if you go to the gym and you
challenge your muscles it's because
you're trying to like be fit and healthy
on the inside and out and so you go
through so what is it that the really
relationships are here to give us a
platform to better ourself in what area
or areas oh well the area of I mean
spiritual growth transcending our egos
transcending our past transcending our
childhoods trans and really just to
teach us how to love I mean when we're
in a romantic relationship that's really
when we are most vulnerable
and that's really when when we love
someone and we romantically love someone
we don't want we want to be loved back
and we and our greatest fear is that the
person is going to fall out of love with
us so that creates that makes us a
little nuts honestly it makes us a
little crazy that's when we like you
know all our walls go up that's when we
cling that's when we become manipulative
and
and the thing about
love is that part of the deal is getting
your heart broken like that's part of
the deal of loving and so when people
get their heart broken
then and the more heartbroken they've
become
or they've the mo the more heartbreak
they've experienced
the less open they are in their
relationships
and then that creates a lot of friction
creates a lot of friction if you're not
willing to communicate if you're not
willing to be vulnerable if you're not
willing to open that causes a lot of
friction it causes a lot of stress
people become very selfish so I think
it's what I think I think it's it's a
spiritual game and I think it's about
learning how to really love not love
from a place of fear not love just
because of you know what was expected of
you but really really love in a way that
um
that isn't about clinging that isn't
about control that isn't about
manipulation so I think that the purpose
of a relationship is to teach us where
our deeper work is to transcend the
things that are the the psychological
and emotional barriers we have to to to
love but it's hard because this is when
we're most vulnerable
it feels like for me the more that I
prioritize myself the more someone else
prioritizes me and the more that I take
care of myself the more I take care of
someone else the more that I love myself
the more that I can love someone else
it really feels like a reflection game
and
um even to even even to receive
compliments for someone to say like you
look really pretty
it's like I'm sure there's a lot of
points in my life where I just would
have been like whatever yeah and and you
don't even hear them right because you
don't believe it yourself so you talk
about wanting like the goal is to learn
how to love
just just really feels like so much
about learning how to love yourself and
take care of yourself
so that you can do that for someone else
that is a big part of it
um for some people it's not just about
taking care of themselves it's learning
how to be less selfish and love for some
people it's about being able to give to
themselves more for sure I think that a
lot of people need to learn how to love
their themselves more especially women
um you know there's this
there's this debate sort of in the whole
therapy coaching world of personal
development World which is like do you
have to love yourself before you're in a
relationship and some people will say no
you learn you learn to love yourself
through relationship and then then
there's this whole camp that says you
have to love yourself before I think
it's and I think it's a combination
really of both I mean I've never seen
anyone who
who hated themselves have a good
relationship I just haven't
um but and you do learn to love yourself
more by doing the work
in a relationship I mean self-esteem if
you have really low self-esteem
you actually have to earn some esteem
for yourself you actually have to do
some things in life that make you feel
good about yourself it's not about
pleasing others or validation but it's
about meeting your needs for some people
it's about making their bed for some
people it's about getting out of bed for
some people it's about you know living
it's all about living up to your
potential for me it's not making the bed
yeah exactly right so for your mission
to not be perfect perversion to not be
perfect yeah I mean perfectionism is is
is a killer you know it just really is
because there isn't because basically
we're chasing a standard that doesn't
exist so then we constantly feel
terrible about ourselves
um but yeah I think that
people who who have a habit of not
prioritizing themselves of not being
loyal to themselves of not loving
themselves are going to choose partners
who are just reflecting that right back
to you so yes when you like you said
when you start to choose yourself when
you start to love yourself you start to
see it reflected back to you and it
definitely does happen I mean that's
definitely the truth of it what are the
most common problems that you see um
let's just stick with couples I mean
what's the most common
common problems not meeting each other's
needs because they don't know what each
other's needs are loving someone the way
that they feel comfortable loving versus
loving the way that the other person
needs to be loved lack of communication
is really I mean all relationship
problems could basically boil down to a
communication problem
I mean if you peel away the onion far
enough at the core what you get is a
communication breakdown because people
get in their heads they start creating
stories they start creating meanings
and they they're we're constantly
projecting and communication is
something that we were not taught in
school and it requires it does not
require Perfection it just requires
courage
yeah it requires vulnerability
and you know kindness
just kindness like hey like did you like
like if you love someone
and all you do is criticize them or
blame them is that loving it's not
so but you could say I really love this
person but your behavior is not loving
so it's it's really teaching people how
to communicate and actually love each
other and for some couples like a lot of
the individuals for example that I work
with it's also about them choosing
better Partners like that's actually a
really big thing because who you choose
really matters yeah I was going to ask
like is it a matter of the finding the
right person or becoming the right
person it's both
it's both
um I I think that who you choose matters
but a lot of people will choose based on
like a checklist instead of choosing
based on what is actually essential own
well-being and psychology
you know although choose people just
based on connection when they don't
really aren't really compatible or they
don't want the same things in life and
so I think that it's one thing it
depends on what you're looking for if
you're someone who's young and you're
looking for like a boyfriend or a
girlfriend you know like someone to just
like and you're not even thinking long
term it doesn't matter so much but when
you get to a certain age and you're
really wanting long term then you have
to choose based on like long term like
you have to have similar visions and
goals and whatnot but ultimately you
know people don't
they don't choose based enough on do I
feel good when I'm with this person do
we communicate do we get through
conflict really well yeah and that's
important
what should getting through conflict
really look like
um willing to talk about it
willing to talk about it because no one
really wants to because most people are
either like seeking conflict or conflict
avoidant I noticed that much more people
are conflict avoidant but there are some
people who are just like I need to fix
the problem now and then there are other
people are like I would rather not look
at the problem and then you get those
two people in a relationship there's a
lot of friction that happens they get
they could be great in every other area
but that is a real problem and so it's
about teaching people to
to not first of all not make mountains
out of Moe Hills because some people
will just take something really small
and make it really big it's like certain
issues aren't going to go away like the
important issues you sit down you talk
about you talk about your feelings
you at you listen to each other's
feelings that's how you restore Harmony
it's really important you don't you
don't finger point you don't blame and
and a huge part of his accountability
and the number one thing that we have to
be accountable for in a relationship is
what goes on in here
it's like all the like how the Neurosis
that goes on in here like I'm creating a
whole story I am projecting I don't even
realize it but I'm projecting mom onto
you I'm projecting dad onto you I'm
projecting my ex on to you and now all
of a sudden I resent you yeah right and
so these are the things and it can be
complicated and sometimes it's
complicated because two people are
really trying to make it work and
they're actually not right for each
other
yeah yeah even though you're good you're
not right right like right because you
can be you can be good but not great and
is there do you see that being an issue
where
it's almost not bad enough to break up
but it's not good enough to make it last
and it's like that fatal little in
between where you know or like a job
even can be the same like it's not that
bad but you know you're kind of like
tolerating it I think that if someone
finds themselves in that situation first
of all it's like every situation is
different if if you're like if you have
a long history and you have children I
think you should fight for that
relationship like if it's if it was once
great and now it's like good why what
are you doing like what have you done to
make it good and not great so it takes
it's a lot of deep inner work and yeah
sometimes you do like you do have to
walk away from someone who's like you
know it's not that it's bad it's just
that it really is just not right how do
you know it's not right well you're you
don't your temperaments don't mesh you
don't have the same values you don't
have the same vision for the Future
these are the things that make it I
think a deal breaker if
if you're you know someone's on the
fence are these the ones that possibly
can be friends afterwards and what do
you think about exes being friends
I think that
um some relationships don't end they
just change form
and so
if so if you have let's say you share
children like your your relationship is
going to change to co-parenting right
like once you have a child with someone
you that relationship never goes away
never ends so you have to learn how to
actually co-parent friends I mean I I
see a lot of people clinging to the idea
of friendship because they don't want to
let go of the actual person but
sometimes you know sometimes
relationships end because
they realize that they are just friends
like they haven't had sex in years or
you know they don't they don't feel
passionate towards each other but they
care a lot about each other and so that
transition into friendship is easier so
I think it's really case dependent
honestly yeah
what about the more casual ones what
about the ones that are like yeah you
know not the ones that were way deep in
it where you had kids and you yeah or
you had a long-term relationship but
what about the Casual ones well whenever
someone asks like should I be friends
with my ex I always respond with well
why do you want to be friends with your
ex
why is it because you can't let go is it
because you have a great friendship
and that was actually really the glue
that was keeping you together
you know or is it just that you just
don't want to let go of this person
were they even a friend to you because a
lot of people would be like can I still
remain friends with my ex but like they
were treated very poorly in the
relationship and it's like well they
weren't a friend to you while they were
sleeping with you
why do you think they'd be a friend to
you now like do you really need another
friend is it gonna get better is it
gonna get yeah they already showed you
so
an area of relationships you were
talking about like this you know
neuroticism and stories that you come up
with and I'm plenty capable of that and
we all are
what how do you guide people and and I
feel like you have a good
would have a good grasp on this because
you you see the stories being told and
you get to the truth many times I'm sure
everybody can omit the truth for sure so
it's like you can't bank that everyone
told you everything no especially in
couples therapy if you're working with
them individually there might be more
learn
how do you tell the difference between
intuition and a story yeah how accurate
are those deep intuitions where you're
just like I just can't let this go yeah
I've worked with people who've never
really had a healthy relationship and
then I work with them and they're and
their wounds and then they start a
relationship for the first time and I
kind of Coach them through that so that
they can have their first really healthy
relationships kind of one of my favorite
things to do and so a lot of them will
have a lot of anxiety and a lot of going
on in their heads and not communicating
well the first thing to do is to
communicate
rather than ruminating is to actually
it's a very empowering thing to do in a
relationship especially if you're
someone who has a lot of anxiety for
example to learn actually how to
communicate and to use your voice so
that's huge how do you know the
difference between intuition and what
you know intuition is something that
that you can that really comes to you in
a calm moment
and you really can't hear your intuition
unless this gets really quiet
but I I think that also one thing that
that people also get confused about that
needs to be addressed is
we're also like on the most Primal level
we're animals right so sometimes our
instinct
is to self-protect
um but it doesn't necessarily mean it's
not needed that it's that it's needed
so it can get tricky but I think so
sometimes when you're like I just have
this instinct to run away it's like okay
well
that's your animal Instinct what is like
your like what is the like quiet or
higher mind say about that so there's
that
but I will say intuition comes to you in
Quiet Moments
and you ha and in order to hear it like
you really do have to get quiet and you
and by quiet it's like your nervous
system has to get quiet you have to get
relaxed
um usually people's Intuition or
strongest right before they're falling
asleep I have found for me personally
it's in the really early hours so it's
like before you actually wake up but
you're starting to wake up that's when
you're in you are wide open that is when
people are most creative that's when
you're going to have your best ideas
that's when you're gonna have
excuse me those thoughts so
yeah and then another thing is if you're
someone who struggles with a lot of
anxiety and creating the Neurosis in the
head and then you you don't know how to
distinguish between that and intuition
this is where mentorship gets really
important having someone really
objective to talk to to help you like
flesh out through like
to move through the the anxious state to
get to a more calm State someone who can
you know who can tell you no you know
what actually you're not being crazy
right now this is actually really real
and you need to address this so that's
how I that's that would be my answer for
that
um yeah that always seems like such a
tough one right stuff in your head and
then you don't say anything and it
builds it's like what's wrong it's like
nothing it's like I don't know
absolutely crazy story in my head I
don't even I can't even tell you right
now no but that's the way to communicate
I have a crazy story in my head and
totally ruminating
oh it's not fair but can we talk about
it what's the right reaction
the right react yeah sure let's talk
about it
what's going on
what's going on in your head tell me was
that the wrong reaction what's wrong
with you relax calm down everything's
fine that's the wrong reaction this
sounds like in something I've read about
like a it's kind of like almost like a
bid for affection in a way a little bit
too like I want to connect with you I
want to share I want to go deeper so how
do you read into those in understanding
the right and wrong way to react that
that you can perceive the reaction or
see the reaction
what about like
you know you've taught you've been
talking recently about like micro
rejections and
um you know things like you know mixed
messages what
how do we sift through all of that to be
able to determine whether or not
we really are in the right situation or
not
well I think it starts with evaluating
oneself
like have you been rejecting I mean
because look
we get Mindless sometimes like you know
we get caught in our own stuff and
sometimes we're just like not paying
attention and the person who you're in a
relationship will sometimes be mindless
it's so like sometimes they're just not
like like no one's perfect
yeah you know no one's perfect and no
one is put on this Earth to be
responsible for someone else's feelings
like first you know like we just can't
be I mean yes it's hard enough for us to
be responsible for our own feelings and
Loan someone else to be able to know
exactly
yes like I mean we just can't the
playing games and and the mixed messages
is usually happening in early in dating
and early relationship and that's
usually where I see it the most yeah and
then people are like they're just
sending me so many mixed messages I'm so
confused it's like okay then this is why
I encourage people open your mouth and
say it
say
I am feeling like there's a lot of mixed
messages
I don't quite understand what's going on
here I really like you and sometimes I
feel like you really like me too and
sometimes I'm not so sure what do you
what are you feeling
but it it you have to be willing to face
the potential of rejection
but I would but Clarity is power it's
really important to have that kind of
clarity
um the micro rejections is just like you
know like hey I'm feeling like I I'm
feeling a little disconnected I've I've
been feeling really attached to my phone
you seem really attached to your phone
can we like maybe just have like some
quality time this afternoon and go for a
walk you know and then the other person
if they're busy or they have something
to do is like the right answer is I
would love that I'm I you're totally
right I can't do it then but I can do it
I can do it you know tomorrow at this
time but that work for you
the wrong one is God you're so needy
just like yeah
like what do you want to do like or just
like it's more an energy it's not even
something that they say it's almost like
you're you're encroaching on my my space
right now yeah you know one of the
frustrating ones
and experience is when someone says
I mean I'm here what more do you want
I'm here I'm right next to you
and you said the word energy but there's
a total difference between someone
that's sitting there and someone that
wants to be sitting there who's present
yeah
it feels like such [__] when it
doesn't feel right and they're like but
I'm here and then it makes you feel
crazy it's kind of like
lightweight gas lighting yes yeah well
so there's two things I'm going to say
to that first of all couples when you're
in a relationship people need to get
better at doing the activities that the
other person wants to do it's like if
your partner wants to watch sports but
you don't like sports like but you want
but you're feeling a little disconnected
from them like watch a game with them
that's because that's their idea of
quality time so we have to really this
is so important we can't just give in
the way that we want to be given we have
to give in the ways that they would
really appreciate so the you know
wanting connection
um is important but sometimes we have to
see the ways in which we can connect
with our partner or see the ways in
which they're they're trying
um so like what do you mean I'm right
here okay
um yeah I I know but I I'm feeling like
um you're right here but somehow we're
just slightly disconnected you must be
feeling like that too from me I mean I
would imagine you are too
yeah it's the truth of the energy you
know when someone's actually like having
a conversation with you but they're not
listening to anything you say they're
like in their heads plotting their reply
I mean how many times have you just you
know you're plotting the reply you're
not really listening
um which it you know sometimes you have
to do like you know when you're
interviewing or something like that but
when you're in an intimate setting like
really listening that's so it's so huge
I mean we weren't really taught how to
really listen to someone when they're
sharing and
a lot of people will complain like a lot
of women will complain that their
Partners don't talk enough to them
well oftentimes what I've discovered is
that they are talking
but they're not really listening you
know or they want it to look a certain
way they want it to be a certain way
like sitting down facing each other
sometimes like your partner is actually
sharing things with you are you are you
listening listen to understand don't
listen to reply yes
um yep yeah which leads me to a space
that feels talked about a lot
I've recently feel like I might not be
as good at it as I thought I was which
is why I'm curious about it
but what does it mean to actually be
emotionally vulnerable or be vulnerable
and we're especially asking this of men
these days yeah
um so to be vulnerable it's a few things
it's it's letting and actually women are
really struggling with vulnerability
women have so many walls up now and I
think that a lot of women are are
wanting their Partners to be vulnerable
first before they open
you know a vulnerable person is someone
who's just willing to kind of share
what's at their inner world with someone
they're they're willing to share
something that they struggle with
they're willing to be open about a
struggle they're willing to be open
about something that really touches them
and moves them
um so it's not just being vulnerability
is not just about discussing the hard
stuff it's just the it's it's willing to
put yourself
out there emotionally for someone to
potentially reject you really you know
it's just something like you something
you like or something you're into like
oh my gosh I saw this cool video you got
to watch this just anything that exposes
what you're interested in and what's
going on inside your head I think
there's a level of vulnerability to that
but I think that there's far more
vulnerability in you know tears watching
a movie
or
saying I'm really I'm really afraid of
something can I talk to you about it
I'm really afraid that you're gonna
leave me I'm afraid that you know my mom
whatever is sick like whatever it is
just sharing what's like really that
that's very deep inside of you that that
feels Raw
it's a skill
it's a skill because so many of us are
walking around feeling very guarded
really guarded it's an epidemic people
don't want to be hurt
they don't want to be seen as weak seems
like there's even there's more
opportunity than ever to be hurt in
relationships because it seems like they
we don't it's not like the 50s where you
just stick it out and yeah I mean they
were hurting too I think and it's a
different way I think they were
definitely hurting but I think that you
know with social media and a million
dating apps and like the threats are
everywhere yeah I think that you know in
the 50s there was just a lot more
certainty it's like we got married we
stay married you know and now it's like
well I can have this option over here
and the grass is greener over there
then maybe I can do that over there and
so
that does make people feel incredibly
uncertain and much more vulnerable to
rejection for sure
well within that realm of social media
and dating apps and things like that
what's the line there like meaning
should you be able to see each other's
information should you like there's
always that there's always that sort of
um issue in relationships where you like
you want to look at their phone or if
you but you you think if I do I
shouldn't be here anyway or if I feel
like I need to I think that if you feel
like you need to look at your partner's
phone there's two things that could be
going on number one you're bringing your
old baggage from an old relationship
into your current relationship or
something is not going well in the in
your current relationship you don't feel
connected you're suspicious of something
trust is the most important thing in a
relationship so you should um not feel
like you have to check your partner's
phone and if you do it's definitely an
alert and and some people I've worked
with they have felt that impulse just
because they've been cheated on in the
past but it's not it really has nothing
to do with their current relationship
it's really about them being able to
build that trust muscle within
themselves
and for others it's because they felt
they felt disconnected they suspect
something is going on but it's not a
good sign good relationships it's like
if you're in a relationship and let's
just say you know it's not an early
relationship like you're in it you've
been together maybe you're married
you're partnered and then you go out for
dinner and let's just say you forgot
your phone but you really have to check
something like important it's like a
work thing if you and then you you
should be able to say to your partner
can I have your phone I have to check
something and they should be like yeah
of course if there is like I think it's
you should you should have each other's
codes only for that there should be so
much trust
so much trust that no one's going to
Snoop so much trust that like there's
nothing that you're hiding that's the
level of trust that is really necessary
in a relationship right because that's
actually the same but different right
there should be so much trust that like
the trust is I'm not going to look at it
but the trust is here's my code yeah
exactly right
opposite sides of the coin exactly what
happens when trust has been broken
depends how it's been broken was it
broken because an affair was it broken
because you know your your partner said
that they wanted to do this for a living
and they decided to Pivot and do
something else for a living you know
they changed in some way was trust
broken because I don't know they didn't
keep a secret what is the pathway back
to trusting especially for both sides
for the person that's learning how to
trust again and for the person that is
trying to earn the trust again
apology and accountability
so if someone has betrayed
a loved one's Trust
they have to be extremely remorseful
and they have to be very apologetic
and very accountable
if it's an affair
you know and I just recently uh
interviewed someone Affairs can be
extremely complicated
and oftentimes what you'll find is that
it's not that it's not a 50 50 split of
who's responsible but even the person
who was cheated on
if they want to work on the relationship
they will see that they played a role in
whatever was not working in the
relationship it does not condone the
behavior right right it doesn't make
them doesn't mean they're not wrong but
it's just that you can see the full
picture you can see the full picture if
you want to repair right if you want to
repair you have to repair what was
damaged in the relationship that kind of
led to that if if it's a big betrayal
like an infidelity they cannot do it
alone you need a third party how early
should that be something that comes into
the relationship
I think that there's a lot of value in
doing it really early on
to learn how to communicate best for a
problem before the problem
absolutely because a lot of people go
into couples therapy when it's become
too late right and it's not even like
when the problem starts it's like this
is like our last ditch effort yeah this
is our we feel desperate yeah yeah so I
think really early on I mean I think
that I'm not a religious person but I
know that in many different faiths
people before they get married for
example will meet with their Rabbi or
meet with their priests or meet and to
have like some sort of counseling to
make sure that their marriage is is
great I think that's a wonderful
practice to be honest I think it's smart
so um I think do it before the problem
yeah
um well something I listened to you said
you learned a lot from
David Dida about masculine feminine men
women yeah and I'm so fascinated with
that area because as we're talking about
you know infidelity or trust issues like
you know I interviewed uh David Buss
evolutionary psychologist and
that like men cheat for variety and
women kind of cheat to leave usually
because they're not happy so I'm like
always fascinated with not only men and
women and what they need that let's
start there like what is it that a man
looks for in a relationship and was a
whim a woman generally look for in a
relationship well I think that men
similar than they are different
um but but I actually don't think so I
think that I want to go back to what he
said because I think it's important
I think the men who chronically cheat
are cheating for variety
but I think when two people love each
other and there's an infidelity
it is because certain needs are not
being met inside the relationship so for
a lot of women
they will they will cheat and have an
affair because at home it's really safe
and stable but they don't but they want
the excitement and they want their
romance again
it's like their partner is sleeping at
the wheel they'd have not turned up the
romance and women need romance
a lot of times men will have affairs
because they feel dead inside and it's
not it's not that their partner's fault
it's almost like if like a midlife
crisis if you will just not feeling like
the purpose and so but either way the
affair is the metaphor it's the thing
that makes the person feel like more
alive again I think that both men and
women get into a relationship for the
same things which is love and
companionship I think women value
connection at a really high level
and I think that typically what you have
found is that men will value sort of
like their purpose maybe at a higher
level but things are changing and I
think that uh both women and men need to
find some sort of purpose I think for
women it doesn't necessarily have to be
through work for every woman but I think
everyone needs purpose but I think both
men and women are in it for the same
thing but where for attraction to happen
inside of a relationship
there has to be polarity there has to be
a duality and so women typically
who are attracted to men and even some
women who are attracted to women
women typically are attracted to
strength and what they will do is
unconsciously test every partner
poke poke at them push their buttons
because what they're doing on an
unconscious level is figuring out like
are you gonna protect me in a foxhole
typically that's not what men are
looking for maybe there's some gay men
who who are looking for that who are
looking for that strength and protection
but typically what men are looking for
is that they want to be they want to
really be appreciated and they want to
actually be the hero
and they really want to be respected in
that way and seen as strong
and they want to like the most
attractive thing for a man who dates a
woman in particular is
is she gonna let me in
am I going to be let into her heart
yeah
or because it's because if it's if it's
constant I don't need you
it's very rejecting
neediness doesn't work either right
right Nita just doesn't work either but
I think that women typically will get
into a relationship to feel a sense of
safety and protection and I don't think
that men value that but they don't value
that as much as women do do you mean
physical safety and protection
emotional physical all of the all of the
above like what does it look to be
emotionally available so I've worked
with many men I've worked with more
women than men but I've worked with a
lot of men and their
Chief complaint in relationships is
I'm not appreciated
nothing I ever do is good enough for her
or for him she's stressed out so much
that I can't I feel like I can't connect
to her heart is closed you know I don't
feel like I'm this is not what they're
saying but this is the meaning behind it
I don't feel like I could be the one who
can just like make her life better she's
not letting me do that this side this
like idea or experience of containment
feels really powerful can you explain
what that is
you mean the the masculine containment
yeah from for a man to be able to
provide containment
yeah so I think that one of the hardest
things for women
and I've worked with plenty of gay women
who have who struggled this with other
women but in general like women with men
is
she can't
it's like his threshold to be able to
handle
difficult emotion is very low
and when I'm upset
he wants to fix it and what I need is
for him to be so with me and so present
and that's actually what heals me in the
moment that's one thing
being grounded
knowing who he is
um
and making it so that she can relax
she wants to be able to relax
yeah but
the problem that that I see with this
between men and women is like so she
just wants to relax
and she can only relax knowing that her
partner is like not judging her for her
emotional states is present
isn't going to be like looking at other
women mm-hmm
mm-hmm you know he's steady he creates
the container container in which she can
actually unravel a little bit
yeah
but
on the other end of the spectrum
women are too often going to their men
with their complaints about the man
and emasculating them
over and over and over again
who they're defeated and they feel
defeated and so this is I'm so
describing just like the most common
problem that I see in in relationships
is
the one person feels totally unseen you
know unsafe like unheard and the other
one feels totally defeated
because they and because in those
moments they don't know how to make each
other happy they don't know how to meet
each other's needs so it's learning how
to work through that
and to figure out what's not working
and to really guide them to a place
where they are
co-creating the best possible Bond and
relationship they can but that's really
the most common pattern I see
is that what do you see as being the
success rate of that because that that
sounds like an indication of perhaps a
lack of compatibility yeah it's not a
lack of compatibility at all it's a lack
of communication and it's a lack of just
skill you know like if you're in a
relationship with a man you have to
understand men a little bit
you're in a relationship with a woman
you have to understand women so having
that understanding of what each other's
needs are is really what's fundamental
it's not a lack of compatibility
necessarily it could be very compatible
but you're butting heads here because I
don't know there's just lots of things
that have stacked one on top of the
other we bring our stress to
relationships all the time we you know
we don't take a lot of responsibility
you know we don't do we don't actually
put in the effort to sustain attraction
there's a lot of things that can happen
over the course of a long-term
relationship that's not just lack of
compatibility but yes sometimes one
person grows and the other person
doesn't grow sometimes people do grow
apart I mean we're not static beings
we're constantly evolving how do we know
what we need like I've said this for a
long time I'm like knowing who you are
is way the F Harder Than You Think like
what and because we're always evolving
too right so yes so you have to ask that
question are but you're you're not just
static yourself so like you're you
changed too
get a good Baseline and keep up with it
I think well first of all every six
months asking yourself that question
understanding what you need is also
understanding where your priorities lie
start with asking yourself like do I
feel safe am I having fun or is it all
work no play
do I feel like I'm do I feel connection
do I feel like isolated or do I feel
like there's Community do I feel like
I'm growing do I feel like you know I'm
giving back like so that's what you
because everyone has those needs
everyone has the need to feel safe
everyone has the need for fun
everyone has the need to to feel loved
needs to me feel also not just like what
I need from you my partner but knowing
what you need for yourself meaning like
am I doing a good enough job like
with my hobbies that I love am I keeping
up with it am I spending enough girl
time are we are we having like healthy
time apart
um am I doing something I actually love
doing for work or whatever you know what
you're doing outside of just for fun
like those feel like
almost just as important as
what you need from someone oh that's
what you're giving to yourself to like
know yourself well enough yeah I you
know we have we have we have work we
have relationships of all kinds and then
we have like our own like physical
spiritual mental well-being and I think
it's just always like okay if I'm
feeling a bit off
a powerful question to ask yourself is
like well what's missing because
sometimes what's missing is just
Community sometimes what's missing is
like you need to have you need to have
some fun sometimes what's missing is you
need like I don't know maybe like one is
not investing enough in the hobbies that
actually make them feel alive and
passionate would you say that one of the
big symptoms of a relationship that
needs attention and work and
communication is
um
sex or lack of
um I think sex is important to a
relationship but not every person values
it the same so it depends on the couple
so not everyone values
sex the same way and it can become
difficult if you're in a relationship
with someone who values it very high and
you value it very low that's very
difficult but you know values do need to
be aligned so not everyone not everyone
values sucks I mean there's some couples
that are very happy having sex once a
month or once a week and there are some
who are like no I need to do it multiple
times a week these are one of the
difficult conversations that couples
need to have is is that if you're in a
relationship and it's important to you
to have something Beyond just
companionship
then be keeping chemistry alive and
attraction alive and your sex lives
Alive is is important and takes
attention what what are what are the
best ways to do that the least sexy
thing is being stressed out all the time
that's not when we're hot is when we're
stressed so if we're chronically
stressed what's happening are we not
giving to ourselves are we not filling
our cup are we not exercising are we not
resting are we not talking to someone so
we have to take care of our emotional
mental well-being that's very very
important because when we do
we're more energized and when we're more
energized we bring that energy to a
relationship and it's sexy
also having passion outside of the
relationship like the hottest thing is
seeing the person that you're into that
you're in a relationship with in their
element it could be like I was talking
to my friend she's like I'm most
attracted to my husband when we're
traveling because that's when he's like
he's really a great traveler he takes
control he speaks multiple languages
they travel overseas so he's just like
he just moves through the Nuance of
international travel so gracefully and
she's like that's when he's hottest to
me you're doing things that are
enhancing that that you get to see that
you know and I think every couple and
it's different for every single one but
every couple has to navigate
the dance between togetherness and
separateness
time together but also time apart
and it has to work for both people yeah
and I think that that's a big part of
compatibility actually is that unspoken
agreement about what feels how much how
amount of time feels apart feels good
like it makes the heart grow fonder
versus not
I saw on Instagram it was
um John gottman talking about
that the things that worked 50 years ago
in a relationship are really the a lot
of the same things that still work today
I feel like the landscape of
relationships is getting tested and
challenged
um you know we look at like open
relationships or polyamory or
Hollywood I don't know there's just like
so many there's so many phrases Words
letters names
so what is it that is like the
fundamentals and what is it that still
works and what do you see maybe changing
and being part of the future of
relationships that's going to be a good
add-in that's new we put so much stock
on in romantic relationships now it's
like I need you to be my soul mate
like people 50 years ago weren't looking
for a soul mate yeah you know and it's
like I need you to be my best friend my
Confidant my this and that and
I think we just put so much stock in
romantic relationships and really we
need to have multiple sources of Love
around us
so that would be one thing change that I
think that you know we have to adapt to
a little bit but also the pitfall is
that now people are like searching for
the one and they want this person
perfect person to check all the boxes
and meet all their needs it's impossible
to meet each other's needs all the time
the basics I mean the basics is just be
kind to each other
the basics is communication
the basics is listen to one another the
basics is have quality time together you
know for some people raise a family
together accepting each other
fundamentally for who you for who the
other person is when you look at really
successful relationships and and I
measure successful relationships with
two people who really like each other
and love each other they're not perfect
but they really really like each other
and and they still want to have sex with
each other maybe not like it was in the
beginning that doesn't last forever but
they're still attracted and they really
just they laugh together they have a
good time together they they move
through they don't have a they have
challenges but they're not constantly in
a state of challenge
those people
they are just really good friends to
each other and they accept each other a
hundred percent that doesn't mean that
they accept or tolerate shitty Behavior
no no but they fundamentally they're
like oh this is your thing this is your
weakness like this is my weakness like
I'm not judging you for that I love you
for that if I'm gonna judge you for that
then we're not right for each other is
it that we always want our partner to be
just like us it's really a big problem
because you don't it's like it would be
so boring we have to celebrate the
differences like there has to be like
you know you need friction to create
fire
so if you're just too much of the same
after a while you don't want to sleep
with too much of the same sure I think
gottman's even says that the amount of
friction there's like a perfect percent
there's there's a yeah a really
successful ratio for like good to bad
um communication but you have to
understand relationship is the sum of
its parts so it's like if a
relationship's not going well what are
the two people in the relationship not
doing well and some people and I've been
there before so it's not a judgment but
it's something that people need to be
aware of and reflect on and that is some
people they have a really bad habit of
just being critical
or they have a really bad habit of
wanting to control or they have a really
bad habit of whatever it is
the more I judge myself the more I judge
someone else yes 100 it's not like it's
just such a reflection like more like I
used to judge people for being lazy a
lot because because you're a
perfectionist
I would never sit around and so the more
I give myself permission to rest the
more I now look at someone resting
instead of being lazy right
like it always seems like it just comes
back to the self yes and that would be
sort of like the shadow work like the
things that really trigger Us in someone
else is the thing that we are so
divorced from in our lives and the funny
thing about relationships is that the
super type let's say the super type A
personality might be attracted to the
really easy going go with the flow
person because they have something in
them that they wish they had inside
themselves or maybe it is inside
themselves but they've repressed it and
so they're attracted to that but if you
don't actually acknowledge it in
yourself if you don't actually then rest
then you're just constantly going to see
that then then that go with the flow
person that you were so attracted to in
the beginning now it becomes like the
thorn on your side but if you can then
learn how to go with the flow if you can
learn how to rest then you can
appreciate more what this person brings
to the relationship we live a lot longer
so our relationships really supposed to
last a lifetime I don't know probably
not
I think it depends what at what point in
your life you begin the relationship is
there a reframe just needed for
relationships ending instead of calling
them failing because as we grow and
evolve it can be beautiful to just it's
always beautiful when you grow and
evolve in a positive way
there's no guarantee that's going to be
with that person and but we look at
every time a relationship ends and we
look at like what's wrong with me we're
in a day and age where people are going
to start to live to 120 I know it's kind
of nuts right
um look there are lots of people who
stay together for 50 years and they're
miserable I mean I see that as a bigger
failure why well because why is that a
success just because you lasted you were
miserable in making each other miserable
so the failure is not saying yes to
yourself and your own happiness yeah
well I mean but that's a slippery for
being honest yeah it's a slippery slope
because look there are people who give
up too soon and there are people who
stay too long and the only thing you can
do is know what your pattern is some
really some people come into our lives
and they're meant to wake us up some
people come into our lives and they're
meant to just like get us through a
difficult part in our life some people
come into our lives and they're just
meant to be like you know they're just
meant to be a chapter not many and that
doesn't mean that because it ended that
it's a failure I think that the hardest
thing is hanging on to people who really
so clearly are just meant to be a
chapter and it's very hard look love is
a is very irrational something a lot a
little while back a couple months ago
that maybe I read it watched it that
chemistry is actually a symptom of a
trauma
and I'm like I am gonna stay in trauma
forever then yeah no I don't agree no
way I'm stepping into a relationship
where I'm not really feeling it but like
you know they're nice
but that statement at all thank God tell
me why tell everyone why chemistry is
important well first of all chemistry is
mostly is is is hormones and
neurotransmitters that's basically what
it is it's it it's smell it's pheromones
it's what not now if
your pattern is to only be attracted to
people who abuse you
in one form or another
your the chemistry that you're having
with people is a result of your trauma
if you're only having chemistry with
people who don't abuse you but it ends
up just not being right
well you have to it's your Chemistry not
is is not necessarily due to trauma but
it needs to be matured
it's like your chemistry is off so
you're attracting the wrong thing so
you're being a TR you're attracted to
the wrong P thing so in other words it's
like okay well I said women are
attracted to strength and so we're
talking heteronormatively right now but
I I I also know a lot of gay women who
are attracted to strength but let's just
stick with this so women are attracted
to strength let's stick with the woman
and the man because this is what I see
the most is an example that I'm about to
share when it comes to chemistry oh you
know he's got broad shoulders he's got a
good job you know he's got a little bit
of an edge a little bit of a bad boy
Edge he's strong I'm attracted but what
she needs to see is that you want to be
attracted to mental strength
and someone who can actually not just
the mental strength emotional strength
someone who will protect you and that's
very important you don't know that until
you actually get to know someone how
many times have you seen walking down
the street and absolutely stunningly
beautiful model level like amazing
looking woman with a man who's really
unattractive and people will say we're
really more common that direction yeah
it's more common in that direction than
the other way right why well she's a
gold digger no she feels safe with that
man
he makes her laugh
he gives her stability
he makes her feel seen sometimes our
picker needs to be upgraded but yeah so
if you're constantly having chemistry
with people who are abandoning you or
abusing you or just not right for you
yes it could be a symptom of trauma but
to say overall that chemistry is just
trauma is is not as I don't agree with
that at all you have to have chemistry
but you have to also
be mature and start to find different
things more attractive you have to some
and some people really have to realign
their picker and a big part of that is
learning to become vulnerable
is learning to actually reveal yourself
it's learning to form deeper connections
with people all right well to sort of
like close up the loop on everything
what is it that we can do to identify
our patterns so that we can improve our
picker and find better partners because
it's not just about fixing yourself it's
about finding the right person as well
so yes so part of that is that we
haven't talked about is some some some
tips on figuring out what our pattern is
so that we can start to become aware
write down like all the relationships
that you've had write down what worked
write down what didn't work write down
some of the feedback that you've gotten
some of the fights that keep on
happening write down the kind of person
your type
because sometimes if you're if you've
been having a really difficult time
sometimes you have to you have to
broaden your type
can't just have one type that you really
don't have a lot of Leverage if you're
only attracted to a certain type and
sometimes the person who's really your
type is the person that's worse for you
because if you're so attracted
that you become that that that your
vision becomes clouded that you don't
see the person for who they really are
that's when we really screw ourselves
over
so maybe that's your pattern maybe your
pattern is you know that you bring too
much stress to a relationship maybe your
pattern is that you keep dating people
who are certain like I said a certain
type so figure out what it is that not
that you want in a partner but that you
absolutely need and just choose three
things that you really need in order to
have build the relationship that you
want to build do you think that you
should come up with deal breakers yes
and they should only be three to five
okay absolute deal breakers and you do
that based on you you study your past
and your history and you study just who
you are figure out what a deal breaker
is and for some people it's like drugs
alcohol smoking deal breaker you don't
want a kid deal breaker they have to be
they can't be your preferences because
if you go by preferences you could be
you could be rejecting the very person
who was really meant for you it has to
be the things that are just like
absolutely not I'd rather die than
tolerate that for a lifetime to someone
yeah you're three months and your three
must not yeah it has to yeah it's very
important but you have to then stick to
that
stick to it and audit it as it goes
along yeah six months every 12 months
like totally and have conversations
about it absolutely yeah
all right cool
thanks Jillian you're amazing and I'm
just gonna thank you watching all your
stuff because it's so good I appreciate
that my friends a lot yeah I really
appreciate that thank you so much thanks
for all your help thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today I hope you enjoyed it if you like
what you heard today and you want to
hear more please click on the Subscribe
button